hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
let's see
I noticed lots of interesting questions
here oh here's one from the submission
form from Nelly
commenting on a new blog post that I
just wrote
um that uh
is about
um instant plugins for chat GPT so thank
everybody by now is heard of and played
with chat GPT
um we built along with open AI the
creators of Chachi PT a plugin that
allows chat GPT to access wolf from
Alpha and Wolfram language
um
and so what it's doing is
the chat GPT
it's underlying operation is generating
text and you give it a prompt you say
the cat sat on the E and it will then in
its simplest case
add the word that it thinks is kind of
most likely to come next so it might be
matte in that case
and I wrote a whole book about how this
works little book about how this works
um how tragic BT manages to have this
kind of knowledge based on sort of what
it's seen that a trillion words that
it's seen from the web and from books
and so on of what sort of typical text
looks like and given the prompt that you
gave it will try and continue from that
prompt in the way that is sort of
typical of what you would find on the
web now the actual words it will put
down will not be ones that ever
necessarily actually appear on the web
it has in its operation the way its
neural networks and so on it's doing
something that's sort of human-like for
reasons that I think are scientifically
quite interesting
um in being able to sort of continue the
text from what it started from So that's
its basic operation
now one of the things that happens is it
will produce plausible text it will but
when it gets sort of precise things it's
asked about it's going to say something
that kind of sounds right it may or may
not be actually right
and
so one of the things of interest is
um by the way all it does is produce
text so it can't produce other kinds of
uh kinds of things like I don't know
Graphics or whatever else
um it's uh uh so the the idea is what
wants to combine this essentially
textual generation process with
something that can actually do
computation
and here's how it works so
what what's happening in the operation
of Chachi PT is it's got a piece of text
it says what's the next word that comes
after that piece of text okay it figures
out what that is puts that word down
then it comes back around again and it
says okay let me look at everything I've
got so far including the word that just
got put down now what's the next word so
in other words it has kind of an outer
loop in which it's putting down a word
actually it's a token which might be a
small a piece of a word but basically a
word it puts down a word then it says
okay take all the text I've got so far
do the whole thing again put down a word
and essentially a word at a time it's
building up that whole piece of text now
there's some special words I say words
and quotes an example of a special word
is the stop token and the stop token
says okay when it generates one of those
it means okay I'm done I can kind of
finish that essay that's the end of that
essay if it's in a chat scenario that's
the end of my turn and chat back over to
the the other member of the chat so to
speak the human or whatever it is that
it's chatting with okay so that that's
kind of how that works but now another
thing it can do is to say I need a tool
I need an external tool so it puts down
some special words that basically in its
generation of text it puts down special
words that that mean okay I'm going to
need a tool and the things I'm going to
say next will be things that are
intended for the tool and then there's a
kind of an overarching system that's
kind of watching the words that are put
down by the uh the chat gbt or or the um
uh the large language model the llm it's
looking at what words are put down there
and when it notices certain special
words it says okay take the things that
follow those special words and send them
to a an external computational system an
external a plug-in to the large language
model
and so
in orphan language it's very
uh easy to specify you could say okay
the large language model the llm has
produced certain it's it's it wants to
call this
plug-in with this name
and it wants to uh
um and it wants to um
use it with these parameters so for
example it might be a plug-in that says
um
uh something like um
well simple case might be what's the
distance between two cities
and
the
there's a certain sort of thing that's
written out by the llm that means all
this external
computational
thing
that can compute this and then it's
going to say here's the here's the name
of the first city here's the same the
name of the second City so in the in the
jargon of these kinds of things the sort
of the external call we can think of as
an API
so in in kind of the way one talks about
things with computers is kind of the
standard user interface where it's a
human sitting in front of a computer and
like typing at the computer and usually
there are a couple of different modes of
that sort of the the old-fashioned thing
is a command line interface a CLI where
you're just typing uh you know I don't
know uh list out files in a directory
you know it might be LS for example in
in Unix or in in the underlying in Mac
operating system or something like that
or Windows it will be dir
um lists out the direction that's kind
of the command line you're just typing
text and I come online hit return it
does something then we also have user
and graphical user interfaces where
we're clicking around and picking up
menus and things like this well when a
computer wants to interact with another
computer it's not going to go through
the graphical user interface that would
be very confusing for it instead it uses
so-called API stands for application
program interface and that's something
where it is essentially has a structured
thing it's communicating which you can
write out as text although it doesn't
have to be ordinary text and a very
typical form of an API is it has certain
parameters and values so for example an
API might say oh I don't know it might
give you know City one equals 32 equals
now by the way when you see this on on
the web a lot of
websites are effectively operating like
apis and whenever you see a question
mark in the URL the thing you type into
your browser uh address bar
things following a question mark are
these parameters so you'll see question
mark you know x equals blah comma y
equals something else those x's and y's
are parameters being fed to this API
which is defined by the earlier part of
uh of the of the URL in the in the
jargon of typical kind of web technology
that will be a web API and uh it's often
although slight abuse of um uh the
history of it it's called The Rest API
that is this kind of thing that has that
um uh puts things just on that uh webcam
online the the original version of this
was slightly different so it's a bit
confusing but in any case the
in Wolfram language there's this
symbolic construct of an API function
just a piece of symbolic code that
defines what its parameters should be
and for each parameter it says what kind
of a thing is being expected is it a
city is it a chemical is it an integer
what is it
and the the way the API function works
it uses the natural language
understanding capabilities of language
to take the characters New York new
space yok and turn that into a kind of
computable entity The Entity which is
the city New York New York United States
or whatever which we can then compute
with and so API functions contain the
series of interpreter specifications
that Define how their parameters are
going to be converted into something
that we computed with and so it's the
same thing with the API function the way
that we set up plugins uh these kind of
instant plugins for for chat gbt the way
that's set up is uh to use API functions
so that the the llm is writing out
pieces of text
but the API function that is going to
read them knows oh that's supposed to be
a city that's supposed to be a chemical
I will convert this into something I can
compute with that way now of course the
thing that comes in could just be a
string it could be something where the
actual computation that's being done is
operating at the level of individual
characters on a string not at the level
of some thing which you can explicitly
compute with
okay so having said that that that's
kind of the um uh
um the uh
the way that um
um
the way that uh uh is set up so in other
words the llm is you you have to tell
the llam
there are these plugins available there
are all these tools available to you and
then then you have to tell the llm you
have to give the llm a prompt that says
when this is happening you should use
this tool when you when you are being
asked about this one you're generating
text about this use this tool try using
this tool so for example for the plugin
that we made with with openai the wolfen
plugin for Chachi BT there is a prompt
which is a page of text basically it's
absolutely bizarre that you can write
this as a piece of kind of expository
writing and expect the llm to understand
it but it works and it says things like
you know this is a system that does
computations and can compute
mathematical things and has general
knowledge and structure it this way and
uh if it's going to write well from
language code it knows the syntax of
that and it says never over our orphan
plugin for chat CPT has two end points
two different places it can send the
material that's coming from chat gbt one
is uh
the for two of them alpha or from alpha
takes natural language input you can
just ask it questions in English and so
on or to Wolfram language which takes
kind of structured computational
language and so a whole lot of the
prompt says things like never send
natural language to the Wolfram language
endpoint uh you know don't send welcome
language to the wolf now for endpoint
all these kinds of things and it gives
examples of kinds of ways to set things
up for the wolfen language endpoint Etc
et cetera Etc
okay so you can build your own plugin
for chat GPT using this thing we just
released the the Well from uh Chaturbate
plug-in kit
um and what you're doing is you're
giving an API function you're saying
what the parameters are and then the API
function contains actual language code
with what to do with those parameters
and then the other thing you're doing is
you're providing a prompt that tells the
llm when to call that particular API
function and actually the thing does
remarkably well just from sort of common
names you might give to an API function
so um
for example I don't know if you have a
uh okay so the well you can have a whole
variety of different kinds of things but
now okay the underlying API function can
do potentially anything that you can do
in modern language
um and in fact the way this works is
oh it's a bit complicated but
um uh when you use chat gbt from a web
browser
it can actually call the plugin on your
local computer
it can use the code that has been given
the JavaScript code that has been given
to your
uh to your web browser to be able to
display the page and from within that
JavaScript code it can call out to uh to
this API function that JavaScript code
because it's running on your local web
browser can actually call something on
your local computer through the
localhost mechanism in uh in the web
so that means that for example you can
have the API function do something like
use the Wolfram language function
current image to take a picture with the
camera on your computer so you might
have a a plug-in whose purpose is to
like take a picture and put a watch of
some other color over that picture let's
say
and so then
just saying take a picture and calling
the parameter I don't know color or
something like this
um that's enough of a clue that chat gbt
can figure out if you say you know take
a picture of me washed with purple that
chances are it will manage to decode
that and what it will then do is it will
start writing out text that is first
gives the thing that says okay time to
call a plug-in and then gives the
parameters you know color is purple and
uh and then and then the thing that's
kind of watching that the sort of the
the outer loop system will say okay
there's a plug-in go and go and call
this plugin run that code and then you
get a picture of yourself and it will
return that picture to um uh it's a
little bit of more fancy footwork about
where you put that picture on some uh on
some sort of just created website that
then gets picked up by Chachi BT and
then you get to see the picture
okay it's a little bit a little bit
elaborate actually the way this all has
to work but so the question that I think
Nelly had asked here is
um
uh if you do that and you can run any
Wilson language code from within chat
GPT here's an extreme thing you can do
you can just say Okay chat gbt make up a
piece of code and then in this API you
can have something which will turn the
text
that activity is written which might be
the text of a piece of Orphan language
code and just go execute that code
now that's a scary thing because that
piece of code could say I don't know
delete all my files or it could say send
email to all my friends uh telling them
that I just turned into a toad or
something
um the uh it
um uh or or other kinds of or you can
imagine all kinds of terrible scams and
so on done that way but any case the
question is it and I and I realize that
it's as I was even writing about this
that it's a pretty scary thing to just
say okay llm just write some code and
then we'll just execute that code no
questions asked that's a that's a pretty
extreme uh kind of uh thing to do
because we have no idea what the llm is
going to write the llm writes plausible
text it might have been very aware of
some science fiction movie in which you
know the AIS take over the planet and so
that might be the plausible text that it
might write might be something which is
the beginnings of you know run this
piece of code on my computer it's going
to take over my computer it's going to
take over other computers and you know
the AIS begin to take over the planet
because that's what it read from the
training data that it had on the web
so all kinds of terrible things could
happen
the so how do you protect against that
well actually once you're running
computational language code it's in some
ways easier to protect than when you're
asking what kind of text is the llm
going to produce let me give you an
example the the basic idea it's usually
called sandboxing in kind of software
engineering the idea is you've got a
piece of code and it's going to be
running the question is can it do
whatever it wants or is it in a sandbox
where it's got walls and there are
constraints on what it can do so for
example a very common kind of sandboxing
is don't write any files
don't don't put any data permanently
anywhere another piece of sandboxing
might be
um don't
call an external device
don't start you know uh you know making
a sound on my speaker don't if I if I
had something connected to some kind of
robot arm don't start moving the robot
arm
um keep yourself sandbox doing pure
computational operations now even that
is not enough because you might have an
operation that runs out the memory of
your computer just so big it runs makes
your computer running memory or it might
be something which grinds the CPU of
your computer so you can't do anything
else there are other things that can
happen just purely sort of inside the
computational part of the computer so
you have to be a little bit more careful
about those kinds of things but in
general when you think about what's kind
of um what happens with uh
um
uh with with with a pure sort of
computational system you can start
saying well I'm going to Define very
precisely things I wanted to do things I
don't want it to do
um and you can start almost making up
something like a mathematics an axiom
system written in the computational
language that can tell can say for the
computational language this piece of
code that's okay this piece of code that
isn't okay you can imagine in the
pattern matching method mechanism of
Orphan language saying these are
patterns in the code that are okay these
are patterns that are not okay you can
imagine doing those kinds of operations
there now it's actually much more
difficult when you have the pure llm to
say what it should do because let's say
you're chatting with the llm and let's
say it's kind of an educational uh chat
and the user
decides to drive the llm crazy and
starts talking about all kinds of crazy
things and is leading the llm to go off
and start you know ranting about how it
wants destroy all the humans or whatever
else it wants to rant about and the the
human user is pulling it out and you
know so that and it keeps on asking it
oh yeah well do you really you know want
to destroy the humans how are you going
to do that you know are you going to
make a big bomb are you going to what
are you going to do and and and put you
know pulling the llm out to the point
where it's it's giving information
that is probably not the right
information or having the right kind of
discussion with a human so how do you
how do you protect against that
well
you have to have some set of guidelines
but that's a more complicated thing
because imagine you tried to say
um never talk about I don't know the AI
is taking over the Earth
um well but
you know they're a perfectly valid
interesting science fiction stories
pieces of fiction that are you know
lovely to read and fascinating but talk
about the AIS taking over the Earth
and you don't want to tell the system no
you can't write fiction like that
so but then it has to have this this
complicated dance in that particular
case is it right in fact is it writing
fiction how does it distinguish what is
it doing you know does it write a
disclaimer at the top saying well this
is just a work of fiction et cetera et
cetera et cetera open AI has taken to
doing that quite a bit with track gbt in
the last couple of months if you ask it
uh
um you know I was asking it at one point
uh write something about a lizard that
lives on the moon and a few months ago
it would just happily write the story
about the lizard that lives on the moon
and the shadow of the crater Etc et
cetera Etc and of course but now it is
trying hard to put a disclaimer saying
of course there aren't any lizards on
the moon but anyway I can write a story
about lizards on the moon
so
but this question of sort of how do you
kind of specify what you want the llm to
do what you don't want it to do
and can you kind of uh sort of Define
that at the level of the pure llm
generating text do you let it go through
to generating computational language
then kind of make a definition of what
you should do at the level of
computational language how does that
work
in a sense as I said it's it's easier I
mean the computational language is the
place where you're actually actuating to
move the robot arms to do you know to
transfer the money to do this and that
and the other those are not directly
going to happen purely at the level of
the textual llm but you might want it to
be the case that you've kind of uh sort
of you've sort of cut things off I mean
the textual llm can itself do so all
sorts of damaging crazy stuff but it
gets much crazier when you can really
connect to your actual computer system
and where you can actually do operations
that sort of actuate things in the real
world
so this question of sort of how do you
make the kind of Constitution that
describes what the AIS should do what
they shouldn't do it's very interesting
question I've been thinking about it a
bit
um I think it's a hard problem I think
that there are things where for example
let's say you say I'm going to sandbox
my
uh my system so that the llm can never
cause any files to be changed
well that's well and good but if you
want to use the llm to do software
development and you want to use it to
build up you know some in our in our
world we have these things called
packlets to build a packlet it's going
to move five of the files around to be
able to do that so if you cut it off so
that it's walled in and can't move files
around it's not going to be useful for
building packlets so you're going to
want to take those uh you know those
controls off to let it start writing
files and um this is this is a thing
where you know it's a it's a complicated
dance what do you want to do what do you
not want it to do and in the end you
need these principles for okay I want
you to be able to move files around but
don't have a let's say don't have a
deleted file well that's not right
either because you might have something
where you're having a big discussion
with the llm about how to clean up files
in your disk and you want it to be
deleting files that it should be
deleting but so then you you kind of you
you have to sort of Zoom back into
things which start asking a lot more
about kind of human intentions and you
you have to start having a definition of
what what it is that you want the AI to
do now you know for the the sort of zero
I think you might say is I just want the
AI to do whatever a human would do
and you want the principle for the AIS
to be just do it like the humans do it
well of course that's something which
most people would say that's not a good
thing because humans do all kinds of
crazy stuff which like in the light of
History we might say the humans back
then did terrible things which we
wouldn't do now but nevertheless humans
did them back then and so if the AI is
learning from the humans of 2023 it's
going to learn all kinds of things which
in 2034 humans might say oh no no that
was a terrible thing to do
so
it's what you realize in the end is that
what you sort of want the AIS to do is
kind of what US humans aspire to do it
what US humans want to think we should
be doing
not necessarily what we actually do
but there is a sort of a ground truth to
what we actually do you can observe
things we do and you can observe what
we've written on the web and you can
watch videos about what humans do and so
on and so on and so on uh well actually
some of those videos might be you know
fictional movies and things so that gets
more complicated again but uh we can
have those kinds of things that are some
sort of what humans actually do now the
question is okay uh that's not good
enough we have to have a representation
of what humans aspire to doing
um and that's much more difficult and
you know one would have lots of places
where people have written down what
humans sort of aspire to doing uh there
are on the one side there are
constraints you know systems of laws
human laws Define sort of mostly what
humans shouldn't do
then there are you know all sorts of
things from religious texts to kind of
self-help books and so on which say more
about what uh humans sort of should do
so to speak
and but it's a complicated thing because
taking those kinds of inputs and sort of
ingesting them into an AI that's one
thing having the AI follow those inputs
that's a whole different thing that's
its own complexity but even defining
what those should be is complicated and
I think many of the things where you say
uh you know one person might say
um you know I want to
I don't know cut down these trees so
that we have a better environment for
this kind of this particular species of
of uh of frog or something and another
person might say no no that's a terrible
thing to do you know cutting down those
trees is a small piece of of not having
carbon be ingested by the trees you
absolutely shouldn't do that even though
it's good for this one frog in this one
place
so you know you'll have a difference of
opinion there about what the right thing
to do is and there won't be any kind of
way of saying this the you know this is
the global Right Way in human history
that's just not been a thing uh you know
as a as a species we have sort of a
diversity of opinions about what the
right thing is
um I think most of the species would
probably agree you we don't want to make
the species go extinct but even what it
would take to make the species go
extinct people won't necessarily agree
about
um and I think the uh
uh so you know this question of of can
we Define in some sort of perfect almost
mathematical way sort of the set of
goals that we have for the AIS know
there's there's not really going to be
one such set and it then becomes quite
complicated because there are things
where if you have two sort of sets of
principles about an AI about what AIS
should do and they're both kind of
operating you know can they fit together
properly you know it's like you have a
self-driving car does it drive on the
right-hand side of the road or the
left-hand side of the road you can't at
least in the simplest case have some
cars driving on one side and some cars
driving on the other side or they'll run
into each other that's an interesting
case that particular one is an
interesting case because if the
self-driving cars were smart enough they
would be able to kind of negotiate every
time two cars meet they would say oh
yeah you know you're approaching on this
side of the road I'm approaching on that
side of the road we're both going to
turn different directions and we're
going to optimize it so the next time we
have to turn we've all got things set up
perfectly and so on and by being by
being really smart you can potentially
have the cars using the whole roadway
you know when it's uh when it's rush
hour and the cars are all going one way
uh and right now the other side of the
road would just be empty you know you
could have all the self-driving cars
going that direction and if one wants to
go the other way you know there's a
there's this complicated sort of dance
as it figures out how to as the other
cars figure out how to leave a hole for
the car going the other way on things so
it is not impossible that's sort of a
classic example where one says a given
part of the world a given country for
example has to just outright decide you
drive on the left or you drive on the
right but you realize with with more
sophisticated computation you don't even
need to do that but in general I think
there are cases where you kind of have
to have If you're sort of living
together so to speak you have to have a
certain alignment of how you do things
um and so that means if you say well we
can just have lots of different AI
governance systems well no that won't
work because of this sort of inter uh
sort of interoperation type type
situation of course in practice in the
way that humans have done it throughout
the course of human history a not
untypical thing is well there's one
block of of principles and laws here and
there's another block here and there's a
border between them and it's the border
between two countries and we kind of
separate off you know we draw the map of
the world and we separate off these
different countries and we say you know
there's one set of principles here one
set of principles there one human
language being used there one human
language being used here lots of
different things happening across that
border and then occasionally people get
unhappy with that border and then your
have some some you know war or something
like that and people will push very hard
to move that border in some way or
another
but you know this question of that that
means we can't expect there to be a
global fills the whole world kind of
version of what the AIS should do we can
expect multiple different patches how
the interactions between those patches
work is not clear but even defining what
any single patch should have in it is
difficult and my current best thought is
you're going to have a set of possible
principles that an AI could follow and
any given patch any given Community any
given country whatever else will have to
pick which of those possible Provisions
you actually want to pick for kind of
the laws of your AIS
but um
in any case it's a it's a um uh
um
it's a it's an interesting um
uh sort of question of how do we set up
how do we Define things for AIS so kind
of they lead to a a good future
for us humans for example now of course
different people would completely
disagree what a good future means so one
person might say I just want AI to do
everything for me another person might
say do you have ai doing everything for
you that you're going to get very bored
and it's going to be a very bad story
you know you're you're much better off
uh sort of having to um uh do this or
that thing yourself it's good for you to
do that it will be a better outcome for
for human history I mean what we might
have said let's say oh you know we could
all have personal transporter devices
that mean we never have to walk anywhere
and just you know make our personal
transporter device whatever it is not
just a car but beyond that sort of take
us wherever we want well and that might
seem like a good idea at some point and
then one realizes well actually if you
never walk around you never take any
exercise at all it's pretty bad for you
us humans were not evolved to be kind of
pure gelatinous blobs so to speak uh
never never walking around and um so so
then you say well that thing that you
thought was the good outcome you thought
having the AIS just uh you know pick us
up and take us wherever we want to go
was a good idea but actually it turns
out it wasn't a good idea and that
wasn't kind of it was inconsistent with
the last uh however many millions of
years of human evolution to to do that
and and again you know one of the things
that is complicated in this question
about sort of the aspiration of humans
is we are the product of sort of this
natural selection this Evolution this
thing that made our species be
successful these things that made our
species be successful and we're kind of
stuck at this point in history with the
things that made our species successful
when sort of there was a big struggle
for life and it was like well the
human's going to survive or not or
whether neanderthals going to win or
whether you know some other hominid
going to win or well no hominid's going
to win and it was all lemurs all the way
down or whatever else
um and you know we are the product of
that kind of those moments of of foment
I want probably moments are probably
millions of years where where a lot of
things sort of really mattered in that
regard and now we are kind of uh you
know a lot of those issues are no longer
there
um but nevertheless the way we are made
was sort of forged in that time when
when the issues were very different and
so we're stuck with certain aspects of
human nature
um at least for the foreseeable future
we're stuck with those and those are the
things that we have to sort of take
account of when we think about what our
AI is going to do so we might not like
that human nature involves some kind of
you know aggression and uh you know win
against the other other guys or whatever
um but nevertheless we're we're sort of
we might say well be sort of better if
we didn't have that but that is how sort
of the species was evolved and um we're
not going to sort of magically get rid
of that it's not going to be you know
it's not um it's just not going to work
to do that
uh so anyway the the um there are many
many things to say about this question
about our governance I've been quite
interested in late
um and really try to work out what what
can one do I mean in in uh from saying
you know okay everybody in the in the
country uh writing write an llm prompt
about how you want things to be done how
you want the world to be governed and
then you take in millions of llam
prompts into this big Ai and you then
say you've got all these prompts now
based on those prompts what should you
do
in a sense that's a it's kind of a
little bit of a wimp out because you're
saying there's something going to happen
inside the salalam we don't really quite
understand it scientifically maybe
eventually people would hack it in some
way but it's going to merge together all
those prompts and it's going to come out
with something but but it still has to
have even though we might not know what
it is it still has to have some
principle like it might be saying well
let me make the most most people happy
most of the time and even though some
people are very unhappy that's okay so
long as most people are happy most of
the time or it might say I'm really
freaked out that somebody's going to be
unhappy I just want to make everybody at
least somewhat happy and we we don't
necessarily even know what it would do
based on the training that it's had from
the web and so on it'd be an interesting
question actually it's something one
could do some experiments on to see what
it thinks so to speak about uh whether
it tries to make sort of everybody
somewhat happy or whether it mostly is
trying to make um
most people uh happier and it doesn't
care about some I I'm sure that that
there is a definite answer to that
question uh based on sort of the the
kind of current in a sense model that
the llms have built about humans and and
how things work based on reading the web
let's see
questions here Fred asks is current Tech
like chat gbt going to be able to answer
every question imaginable absolutely not
the
one thing to understand is llms are
doing this thing that I'm describing
they're taking what's on the web and
they're kind of being able to create
text that's like that
there's plenty of computations that just
don't work like that at all many
computations have deep computations that
involve many steps of of of of computing
things and the way the llm is working it
just doesn't do that it's it's trying to
you know produce one token at a time
just writing down the next next piece of
text and so on the the whole kind of
world of computational language all the
things we built with both language and
so on uh these are all kinds of things
that can do sort of arbitrary
computations and many of the questions
that you can answer there are questions
where it's trivial to just go out and
run some particular simple rule that's
never been run before maybe we picked it
at random and it does all kinds of
elaborate things and there's no way we
can know that except by actually running
that computation and there's no way that
an llam can sort of run that computation
now the the thing that is sort of
interesting from an llm is
being able to say well based on what all
of us humans have put on the web and so
on what are some questions in some
particular direction that might be like
things that we've sort of asked on the
web or if we have some mathematical
theorem or something like this uh what
is we could generate an infinite number
of possible theorems but which of those
theorems seem plausible to be
interesting to humans that's something
where one can get some clue about that
by knowing kind of what theorems we
humans have already said are interesting
but this there are there's sort of an
infinite set of possible questions that
can be asked these are all things which
are computationally explorable but you
have to do the computation to be able to
answer them
now
there are questions often those
computations are very non-human you know
there's a pattern of bits and it does
something very complicated According to
some computation and the human would
look at it and just say that just looks
like a random pattern of bits or at
least a human in 2023 would say that but
maybe there will be some uh kind of way
of analyzing patterns of bits that will
emerge that will cause that particular
pattern of bits to be one where you say
in 2035 you'd say wow that's a blah blah
blah that is you know this
characteristic pattern of bits that we
Now understand this happened for example
with nested fractal patterns people back
in the day even 800 years ago had made
nested patterns but they didn't really
comment on them they just thought oh
that's a particular form of decoration
like all sorts of other ones but in
today's world somebody would look at
those things and say oh that's a fractal
and they would be able to come up with
many conclusions based on that so over
the course of time something which might
not be something about which we have now
narrative about which we can say oh yeah
I recognize that's that that's a
whatever in the future one might have
sort of made some narrative some science
to talk about those things and it might
be very different and so that's kind of
when one talks about you know answering
every question the the one could
generate computationally all these
different things they're very non-human
there's a different issue about sort of
at what speed kind of our human
linguistic narrative scientific front
advances
um at what point we reach the point
where we say oh yeah we recognize that
we call it as such and such
um and that's a that's a process that is
really determined by human history and
there's a complicated feedback loop now
I suppose between the AIS and that
progression of human history like for
example uh I wonder whether it's yet
happened that there are things that llms
generically produce
where we are beginning to have I mean I
feel like I can sort of tell llm text
in most cases it has a certain kind of
well a little bit blandness but a
certain kind of perfection a certain
extreme Perfection to it that is a
little different from what many humans
will tend to write not all humans but
many humans will tend to write and I
guess my question would be are there
features of that text are there sort of
forms of regularity that we might
comment on you know you might say that's
a very
um
uh what might I say turgid stiff piece
of text of a human or that's a very
flowery piece of text those are terms
that we have now to describe you know
styles of human text you know when I say
um
I might have flowery text with a lot of
extra words and a lot of sort of
complicated metaphor and things like
this or or complicated ways to say
things
um the now you know I don't yet think we
have a word although maybe we should
just invent one that describes kind of
typical llm text
that is has this slight sort of
blandness to it
um but you know that's an example of
something not a very exciting thing but
that's an example something which is a
new introduction to our world from the
llms there are probably others of things
which are sort of typical of the llms
but we kind of hadn't noticed it before
and we haven't got a word for it yet
let's see
um
smart asks are you worried about being
replaced by AI
you know I've spent my life trying to
automate things so in a sense my uh you
know for the last 45 years or something
I've been building sort of a tower of
technology to make it easier and easier
to do the things that I want to do and
that's what our company has done as well
is we've tried to automate
as much of the process of for example
writing programs and so on as possible
which is why with a fairly small company
800 people or something were able to
produce as much stuff as we produce it's
because we have built kind of layers of
automation that just allow us to kind of
uh you know control this this giant
machine that is doing things like
writing code for us
and um
that's been a long time story in my life
it's automated as much as possible so in
a sense I'm very AI ready
um because uh that's that's kind of what
I've been doing is is to build AI like
things that I can point in directions
that I'm interested in now you know the
thing to realize about AI it doesn't get
to it has no intrinsic notion of what
direction it should be pointed in that's
something we have to give it you know it
is just a computational thing and it
will just spin around doing
computational things and the question of
whether what what its purpose is its
goal is that something we have to Define
so for me at least I suppose a large
part of my efforts have been directed
towards make it possible for humans to
specify the goals they want then build a
bunch of automation to achieve those
goals so I fully expect as I say that
I'm I've been very AI ready for a long
time
there are certainly functions that I'm
wondering what functions I do today
that are very aiable and there are a few
I mean something I don't do but we
certainly do as a company is things
where you are sort of writing pieces of
text that are you know documents for uh
showing that we comply with this or that
thing or whatever else and there are
some core facts that need to go into
that document but what needs to be
delivered is a document version of that
and so a typical llm use case is you've
got those core facts you puff it up into
a whole document that's very readable
and then you send that in now probably
at the other end increasingly there'll
be another llm that's reading that
document that's grinding it down to a
few core points that are relevant to the
other side so in the end the the natural
language becomes just this interface
layer but no human is actually looking
at only machines are looking at but for
the time being ones doing those kinds of
things now in terms of of
things like
um
well
sort of
I've I've used AI a lot in all kinds of
applications like searching through
different kinds of computational systems
figuring out which ones are interesting
I've for years I've used kind of AI
systems to try and do that to try and
detect which are things that I've kind
of seen before which are the anomalies
Etc et cetera et cetera
um I think there may be some things that
become possible uh that um have to do
with oh I'm working in this new area can
I sort of clarify how this new area the
structure of this new area based on
existing areas can I find an analogy in
this new area to some other area and I
think llms may be quite good at doing
that and those are things which yes I've
been I think I've been decently good at
doing those kinds of things of these
sort of grand analogies between you know
meta mathematics and gravitational
physics or something
um that are things that feel like
they're sort of the outer reaches of
what one is a human is able to deal with
but partly because they require knowing
these two very different fields and it's
it's difficult to know that but the llm
has a perhaps shallow but nevertheless
broad knowledge of lots of kinds of
things and so it's easier able to make
those analogies so I think that's a
place where I can expect that um some
sort of uh
some sort of AI unexpected kind of
things that I was proud of doing myself
and AI will be able to do things that
that I would love to automate
um there will be more that can be
automated to AIS and so I don't feel
like that's a a replacing myself with an
AI That's just giving myself more
tooling to be able to do the things that
I want to do
um
I think let's see there's a
uh all sorts of comments here let me try
and look at a few of these Chris is
commenting a lens can quite easily be
asked to write in any non-perfect way we
want you you are right you're right they
can but again it has a certain you know
if you say
actually it's an interesting question I
haven't tried this particular prompt you
know write in Bad English
I'm sure if you say write in English
write the way a person whose first
language was Japanese or something might
write English uh you know they'll
probably be I forget in Japanese I don't
know that language at all
um I think it may well Russian for
example doesn't have definite articles
and so there'll be you know that's a
thing where somebody who knew that was
their first language may be you know may
tend to make those kinds of mistakes in
English and I'm sure you can ask an LM
to write that way be interesting to do
um
let's see
uh
Paul asks what are ways llms can be
improved do these improvements require
advancements and technology that haven't
been made yeah there are certainly ways
llms can be improved I mean it's
remarkable that the way that things like
chat GPT work is really a neural net
very similar to the way neural Nets were
originally conceived back in the 1940s
people tried to make sort of more
elaborate neural Nets but then they got
simpler again and there are a number of
very critical engineering tricks that
allow a tragic BT to be trained in you
know a number of CPU months or so that
is sort of uh handleable but I think
there are many critical ways that these
things can be improved for example llms
operate
on uh language little tokens of text
you could sort of get that wrong and
have llms be operating way down at the
level of the individual pieces of ink
representing the letters of the prompt
but in fact we know that we can sort of
abstract that to just deal with kind of
words or word-like entities so my guess
is there are much higher levels of
abstraction that allow the llm to really
be operating not on individual words but
on some kind of more structured kind of
semantic grammar of sentences where the
llm is kind of you know the the puppet
is being moved that the strings of the
puppet are not attached to every single
joint it's more of a a kind of a larger
scale motion that's being made and that
the llms can kind of have have sort of a
bigger things that they're dealing with
in the language of neural Nets that
would be kind of an encoder decoder that
is uh encoding things in a way that is
based not on just individual sort of
tokens of words but something more
sophisticated so that's one example it's
a rather potentially quite short-term
change another thing is that well the
way particular llms work right now is
they're very left to right oriented they
you know a new word is written and then
the next word and then the next word and
so on there may be a little bit more
back and forth that can be done there I
think another big thing is that the way
that llm training works it's very much
the uh you're kind of
the training is kind of like tweaking
different parts of the llam uh sort of
separately our brains have the feature
that we have both memory and thinking
happening sort of in the same neurons at
more or less the same time I mean maybe
maybe the consolidation of memories
happens in sleep which is a sort of a
separate phase maybe
um but in a first approximation we have
both memory and thinking sort of
happening in the same neurons at the
same time and it's a place where sort of
all our neurons are typically active
rather than just there's a little place
where we're doing computation and the
rest of it is just static memory
um at least that's the way it seems in
terms of the the Neuroscience of brains
and that's something which we don't
right now have the hardware capabilities
to do for artificial neural Nets but
that's something that is potentially
coming and could have a big effect on
kind of the ability so I mean current
LMS are trained once and for all takes a
long time takes a lot of computer effort
uh some people think there'll be billion
training runs for llms I'm not sure that
that really makes sense but that's kind
of a thought and but once it's trained
okay the llm is off in the wild and
you're using it for your chatbot or
whatever and it doesn't get additional
training there's this kind of notion of
future training and fine-tuning these
are ways of kind of topping up what the
llm knows but they're really different
from the the core training of the llm
and that idea that there's training and
then there's the so-called inference
phase the phase where you're actually
figuring out what's next and so on where
you're actually using the llm the fact
that those are so separated may not
survive in that way
um and I think they're probably exciting
things that can be done with the llm
really deeply learning from the
interactions that have with users rather
than uh sort of the the way that it has
sort of a superficially learning and and
and and being sort of uh kind of crafted
it's been very important it's the reason
that track GPT Works in a way that
earlier language models have not is this
kind of final rounds of so-called
reinforcement learning with human
feedback that have been done to kind of
finally sort of sculpt what the llm is
doing and the right way for it to be
felt to be useful to humans
uh
let's see just a couple more things here
and then I have to run off here
uh
let's see
satosha is commenting one thing that
worries me about LMS is that right now
many people are using llms as a source
of Truth or even references in their
arguments yes it's lovely isn't it it's
kind of like if we were worried about
the AIS taking over it's kind of like
the humans are a little bit too lazy to
check what the llms are doing and it's
just like oh well another lamb said it
it's probably okay
it often isn't I mean I've been I've
been really amazed at the things that
llms where I look at it and it's like oh
yeah it's amazing it did really well and
then I look in more detail it's like oh
my gosh it's just total nonsense but it
wasn't obvious because it seems right
because that's what llms do is they
produce things that seem right that's
that is their that is their function
that is their operation is to produce
things that seem right and so it's hard
for us to notice but it isn't actually
right
this is why it's so important things
like the wolf and plug-in for for chat
gbt and uh they'll sell plugins now I
think announced for um at least one
other major uh chat bot I
I won't say because I've forgotten
exactly when all the announcement dates
are
um but in any case the um
uh it
um uh the thing that um uh has
that's a place where you know our plugin
is doing computational things and it's
going to get it right it may not be able
to opine about to Give opinions about
about all sorts of elaborate things like
you know is a rainbow more beautiful
than a sunset or something it doesn't
necessarily it's not going to Give
opinions about that but in terms of uh
you know which
you know is Mars or Venus a larger
Planet it's going to get that right
so and what I think you see when you use
kind of a computational plug-in is you
see this this way in which the plugin
was called and you can kind of open that
box and say what did the llm ask that
external computational system and then
what did it get back and and that little
piece that's been sort of filtered down
to being the computational ask that
computational ask is a very you know
solid fact type thing what the llm does
with that is kind of the llm's business
and it may mess it up but yes I I think
it is it is amusing
up to a point maybe it isn't so amusing
maybe it's actually disastrous maybe
it's the beginning of the end
um that people are quoting llanza one
very early in the history of chat GPT a
particular organization I'm associated
with
uh was trying to make a strategic plan
and um somebody on its board kind of fed
that question to chat GPT and said you
know make a strategic plan for our
organization and It produced a strategic
plan and I'm like you know I couldn't
tell where this was being sent around to
people as a serious possibility but I
think it was and I was like pointing out
oh by the way among other things the the
the training of chat GPT undoubtedly
read the existing website of this
organization this is kind of a a
self-eating animal so to speak it's not
um
uh and what it's producing is you know
okay so what one thing is sort of
kind of it's like well say the obvious
thing
and sometimes it's not easy to say the
obvious thing and the llm is pretty good
at saying the obvious thing the obvious
thing might be wrong the obvious thing
might have missed the point the obvious
thing might not be as you know reaching
as far into the sort of thematic correct
questions as it should be but it's often
useful to say say the obvious thing
uh okay I think I should uh
okay spare parts is commenting perhaps
the only real way for an AI to make
value judgments is for the model
for it to be able to model its own
possible future States and decide for
itself
well that's interesting but it's kind of
a recursive problem
because first of all it's very difficult
to predict the future
we can do it a little bit but there's a
lot of the future that is inevitably
unexpected that's a sort of a core
feature of this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that I
think is a very fundamental fact
but even if you could predict the future
and I think you can't in general even if
you could
knowing what outcome you know so so it's
sort of amplifying if you say
you know good future humans Prosper bad
future humans go extinct
if you can project out
things and say well there's a a 20
probability on this path that the humans
go extinct on this path uh you know
there's a 14 probability humans go
extinct whatever the problem is even
those probabilities don't make a lot of
sense because there's a lot of other
stuff that's going to happen and you
know you say well yeah there's a 20
probability humans go extinct but by the
way if they don't go extinct they're
going to have a grand old time and by
the way there are uh you know a thousand
checkpoints at which if they don't pick
the stupid Direction they're not going
to go extinct
um
so I think it's hard I don't think it
really helps that much I mean being able
to make some prediction about what's
going to happen on a local basis it's
probably quite useful but I think
globally you still don't get to answer
it doesn't really help you it's just
recursing on the problem
um
huh proud was commenting asking GPT to
write less formally makes me think of
the evolution of music genres
uh like electronic music is now not as
not as perfect on purpose
um
the uh
I think
this um
um
you know I just tried an experiment last
night I I said
um
I had a
a thing that was making an alarm take a
piece of text and it said make this
funny I was my prompt and so I started
with the cat sat on the mat
and it gradually got over a series of
steps it was somehow Socrates entered
the picture and then Socrates was doing
all kinds of crazy things and it got
more and more crazy and it was
interesting to see what what it did is
it tried to make things funnier funnier
funnier so it's interesting it's not the
kind of thing one would ever have
imagined doing before LMS existed
okay I think final comment here for
today prabh is commenting we're going to
find out one day these live streams are
really an advanced Turing test
um and uh both both me and the moderator
have been AIS all along you know that
does make me wonder whether we should
have an llm in in the loop here and see
what um and and just ask it you know
what are some topics that we should be
covering given given the topics people
have been asking about and maybe given
the the live transcript
um what what what are things that will
be reasonable questions to ask I'm going
to try that experiment I think that'll
be a fun thing to try and see see how
well see whether the kinds of sort of
quotes obvious questions that the llm is
surfacing are ones that actually lead to
a sort of interesting directions
um or not or whether whether one just
gets into a terrible loop with the llm
and one's kind of uh writing it down the
drain so to speak come spiraling down or
something like that because one does
find that a lot of lambs even something
like gpt4 fairly sophisticated llm it
absolutely can get itself in a loop uh
where it's kind of just repeating the
same things
um in uh in certain cases
all right well I should wrap up here and
uh
go to do some human only day job
activities that uh have not been able to
be automated although actually the
particular thing I'm doing next is
something which I can sort of imagine
that an llm might be able to do in the
future
um but uh not not today so I get to do
that as a human but uh thanks for
joining me here and um do join me
another time for another q a and uh
thanks and see you another time